we know this climate scientists know
this uh whether people know it it's a
problem and so people who are talking
about the simulation hypothesis kind of
we totally ignore the problem that we
have with putting our reality on a
computer
you've got a quote at the start of your
new book that says it is far better to
grasp the universe as it really is than
to persist in delusion however
satisfying and reassuring it's from carl
sagan what's that mean to you
when i came across this i i just thought
this captures exactly what i'm trying to
express with the book
um so it's very tempting to fall for
some
pleasant explanation uh and try not to
look at the evidence
but i think in the end it's better to
actually look at the evidence at least
for me so so that's been my conclusion
because otherwise you always have this
feeling that you're lying to yourself
um do you feel like your twitter account
is mostly you dashing the dreams of
people who have
non-evidence-based ideas about what
might be happening in the world or in
the world of physics
well except for the animal pictures
basically um
but yeah well um you know partly the
reason that i was writing this book is
that i felt
um what i do on social media is a little
bit
too destructive a little bit depressing
almost um if there's some
headline that claims well soon we'll be
able to send information faster than the
speed of light with the quantum internet
or physicists have uh created negative
mass or that kind of stuff then i'm the
one who has to say well actually no you
can't do this and it doesn't work and no
we have not made contact with parallel
universes that kind of stuff
and i i do think it's important but it's
a very one-sided picture of physics it
it raises the impression that physics
just tells you what you can't do
what what isn't possible
and i think physics has another side
where it opens new possibilities it
tells you what you can do um it brings
up um
new ideas that you might not have
thought about otherwise um so rather
than just playing defense all the time
there's the opportunity for you to put
forward some ideas
well not my own ideas i'm talking about
uh stuff like the multiverse or um i
mean other ideas that have already i
would say an almost established place uh
in
the public mind is ideas like that time
slows down near black holes or wormholes
or maybe teleportation
those are all ideas that came out of
physics and i think it's really
inspirational and i understand that
people like it and they want to hear
more about it and and so i thought well
write a book about all those big ideas
speaking of ideas that have captured the
public consciousness the simulation
hypothesis is something that's been
thrown around an awful lot what's your
problem with the simulation hypothesis
so the simulation hypothesis is the idea
that our reality is just a computer
program basically and uh once you buy
into this uh there needs to be some kind
of programmer who has written the code
and um
god knows what this programmer is doing
maybe he is god
um and so i think that as um
you know a talking point over a glass of
wine uh that's well and fine or maybe
philosophers want to go on about it
that's also fine but if you claim that
it's actually based on science that's
when i get a problem because it's a
pretty big claim about what it takes to
reproduce our observations and uh it's a
claim that says well you can reproduce
everything that we observe
um with
an algorithm put on a computer
and i want to see the algorithm show it
to me because basically um you just
claim that you have a theory of
everything
and that falls into the terror of the
foundations of physics which is where i
work
and so i think philosophers who
write about it and make statements like
oh well um you don't have to think about
um
the computational capacity of the
computer because if there's some corner
of the universe where no one's looking
at the moment you don't have to compute
it i'm like yeah well you know show me
how you want to write this into the code
so i'm just not buying it i think those
people are um they're trying to get away
too cheaply
because it's a problem that's put
forward as a philosophy problem right
it's like a
an idea playing with interesting ways
that the universe perhaps could exist
but i think your argument is that you
need to drag that across into physics
it's not really a question of philosophy
so much as it is a question of physics
well it was put forward by a philosopher
and it has certainly been discussed by
philosophers like i think david uh
what's his name chalmers has just
written a book about it um which i
haven't really read i've looked at it
but i i would not um pretend that i
actually read the whole thing
uh and it's it's fine to discuss you
know on this abstract basis maybe one
day there'll be someone who'll be able
to write a code on some kind of computer
you know on that level but when you when
you're making a claim that it is
actually possible for we currently know
about the laws of nature and what we
know about computers they don't think
that's pushing it too far and i think
that some people have made claims about
it like like elon musk for example and
um
neil degrasse tyson is one of them who's
made statements about it i think they
they over emphasize how much of it is
actually based on science and that's the
point where i get a problem which bit is
not based in science the fact that we
don't have the computing power or the
algorithms to be able to do this
well we don't have the algorithms we
don't even know how to do it like i mean
they're they're really basic problems
with um how do you describe a chaotic
system this is something
just to stick with this example that
climate physicists have to cope with uh
in reality and it and it's really
difficult because as you probably know
um you have something like the
navier-stokes equation it's scale and
variant so strictly speaking you can't
just ch chop it off at the finite grid
uh what do you have to go go into that
well um what the navier-stokes equation
is
equation is the equation that describes
how um fluids and gases behave uh for
example the atmosphere but also oceans
water and that kind of stuff um so
it's like the central equation that you
have to solve on a computer if you want
to describe the weather or the climate
uh in the long run and uh this equation
has the property that it's scalar which
basically means it um it it draws on all
different scales like the long ones and
the very short ones
but if you want to calculate what
happens for the globe
you can't actually on a computer you
can't really calculate it on all scales
so what you have to do is you put a grid
on it
and
the resolution of the grid depends on
whether you want to do a calculation on
a country basis on on the entire globe
and for what time span but typically for
climate models
it's right now i think something on on
the order of several tenths of
kilometers and maybe four weather models
they can go down to one or few
kilometers so i'm not a climate
scientist i hope this is roughly right
it should be kind of in that order of
magnitude
but that's clearly not scale invariant
um so you you've modified the
equations uh and that has consequences
so that that they're just situations
which those models will not correctly
predict and we know this climate
scientists know this uh whether people
know it it's a problem and so people
were talking about the simulation
hypothesis kind of we totally ignore the
problem that we have with putting our
reality on a computer
and that's only at the scale of a world
or perhaps even a country with the grid
size or the pixel kind of the pixel
equivalent of one square kilometer
perhaps so trying to make something
that's planck length across an entire
universe is signific okay i understand
so if we can't simulate a universe can
we create one
well that's that's an interesting
question um
i i made a video about this and i was
trying to argue that um if everything we
know about um
the early stage of our universe is
correct that's a pretty big if but let's
just assume it is correct
then the answer is yes quite possibly
one day we'll be able to make a universe
and
a lot of people thought i was joking
because they know me as someone who who
usually says no you can't do this this
is all rubbish don't believe it and this
was another reason why i wanted to write
the book because i felt that i've
maneuvered myself into a corner where i
i'm taking this very this very negative
destructive point of view um
how is it that it could be possible for
us to create a universe but not simulate
one
well um
that's a very good point
yeah well it's it's it depends on the
question what you mean by um a
simulation and what people normally talk
about they talk about a computer that
has been programmed by someone and
that's something which you would not be
able to do with this universe um you
would just create the conditions under
which it comes into existence uh and
then what at least for for we currently
know about how those things work it
would create a small bubble basically
and that would pinch off from our
universe so it goes away you have you
you don't control it um you don't
program it um it probably inherits most
of the conditions from our universe and
um you can never get into contact with
it again would you ever actually be able
to know if you'd created one in that
case
well that's a good question um
you have to think about
some observers observables that would be
related to it and people have thought
about some um unfortunately it would
look pretty much like a tiny black hole
so it might be very difficult to tell
apart
uh but um i should probably add like
this is not something we're going to do
in the next 1 000 or maybe 10 000
years it would require to put
a macroscopic size of material so
estimate say something like 10 kilograms
into a particular quantum state where
that kind of stuff
could happen
so it's theoretically possible there's
nothing in principle that stands in the
way of one day doing it but it's
certainly not something that's that's
going to happen in our lifetime okay no
new universes just yet so what about
free will that's something else that's
been popularized people like dan dennett
and sam harris over the last few years i
actually had a friend who uh i spiraled
into a three-week depression by sending
him a video of sam harris explaining
free will on joe rogan and uh after that
he came out on the the other side
actually been quite thankful for it but
for those three weeks i'm sorry luke um
what about physics relationship to free
will what have you come to believe about
that
yeah i've i've been there
but it took me much longer than three
weeks um so it's one of the reasons why
my book has kind of a warning uh in the
beginning when like some of the things
that we're going to talk about uh are
not easy
and i think that it's one of those
points but i also think uh that um
you know everyone who knows something
about physics um
will stumble over this problem sooner or
later so let's just talk about it and
then you can get through it and come out
on the other side and and i hope that my
book facilitates that
um and so yeah i'm basically i'm i'm uh
i'm with uh sam uh i like his book uh i
mean to begin with it's a very short
book so i can really recommend it you
get through it very quickly i like the
book except for the one paragraph that
he has about physics when i came i think
that this wasn't quite right there was
something about the planck scale which
uh book would have been better without
that paragraph uh but yeah i mean so
that's this basic problem that um for
all we know about
the the fundamental laws of nature they
are a combination of uh determinism
where the future is predicted by what
happened in the past and then every once
in a while there's some random event
that comes from quantum mechanics but
you can't influence it um because
nothing influences it it's entirely
random and
now
whether you think that this rules out
free will or doesn't depends on what you
mean by free will so this is why there
is so much debate about it so the way
that i've tried to approach the problem
in my in my book
is by just first explaining what we know
about um the laws of nature which is
what just said this combination of
determinism with the
occasional random quantum jump and then
you can ask well does this mean that
free will does not exist what do you
make out of this now personally my
conclusion from this is just well free
will doesn't exist let's get over with
it um and you know think about ourselves
in a different way
um but of course you can try to come up
with different definitions for free will
and this is something that david alberts
has done for example and other people
have put forward slightly different um
definitions and this is all fine with me
so long as we know that we're talking
about different things um
what is it
that's happening at the quantum level
that's causing this random chance
because as far as i was aware
it means that had you have gone back and
run the same period of time again that
something different could have happened
but i thought that given the initial
conditions everything is predetermined
from there but it seems like you're
saying there is a genuine roll of the
dice here which could one times come up
with a one and the next time come up
with a three of some kind
if you take quantum mechanics seriously
the way that we use it right now that's
exactly what happens of course you can't
actually go back in time and run it
again so there's a slight problem with
that
but at least the way that the theory
works
there are occasionally those measurement
events
for which you can't predict the outcome
you can only predict the probability of
getting a particular outcome
uh and uh
those are generally random they're
they're indeterministic so quantum
mechanics is an indeterministic theory
but of course um quantum mechanics may
fundamentally not be correct it may just
be an approximation to something else
that's going on and that's something
else might be deterministic again
and then as you certainly know there's
also the many words interpretation which
tries to do away with uh the the
measurement update uh entirely so then
you only have the deterministic
evolution left so it's it's somewhat
controversial but um
yeah i mean i i think for what the
discussion about free will is concerned
it doesn't it doesn't really matter you
know you either have a deterministic
evolution with the occasional random
event or you have a deterministic
evolution without the occasional random
event but in both cases i find it
difficult to make sense of privilege yes
because am i right in thinking the many
worlds is where you branch off each time
that something occurs is that right
yeah basically so when in in the
standard interpretation which is often
called the copenhagen interpretation um
you make a measurement um you collapse
the wave function in one into one
definite outcome but you don't know
exactly what so which outcome so that's
that's the indeterminism uh in the many
words interpretation you don't collapse
the wave function you just say well now
there there are two universes or three
or four or five uh depending on how many
possible outcomes uh there would have
been um and each of them happens in its
own universe yeah so what that would
mean is that each universe is
deterministic because you are following
down the path of one
if you continue to go down that that
would mean that that is the only way
that that could have come out and all of
the others are also deterministic is
that right
um
no actually what's deterministic is the
entirety of all universes right but if
you if you are in one of those universes
it'll still look indeterminate and this
is exactly what we see right it looks
indeterministic ah i see
so is it right
you often hear that if we had known the
initial conditions of all of the mata
at the beginning of the big bang we
could have accurately predicted
everything that was going to occur for
the rest of time going forward is that
not true
well in the many worlds interpretation
it would be true for the collection of
all those parallel worlds um in our
universe um if you collapse the wave
function it's not true because you get
this you get this random
quantum element and it's not necessarily
the case that um those quantum
events remain small they can certainly
grow into macroscopic differences and
this is what schrodinger tried to
illustrate with his famous cat thought
experiment
so he was trying to say look it could be
that um you you have a cat that's either
dead or alive depending on whether or
not an atom decays and so what it
basically does is that it amplifies this
indeterministic outcome
from a tiny macroscopic quantum thing
which is this atomic nucleus uh too big
thing which which is a cat but it could
be you could be the entire planet you
know if you i don't know you blow up a
bomb or something like that
going back to the beginning of the
universe then
what are people getting wrong with the
way that they currently look at the big
bang the origins of the universe what
are the claims that you've been
uh beating over the head on twitter or
elsewhere
yes so the problem is that um we have a
fairly well established theory of how
the universe evolves and yeah there are
some niggly bits with dark matter and
dark energy but let's leave this aside
for the moment so we have einstein's
theory of general relativity that tells
us how the universe as a whole um
changes in time if we know the matter
content matter energy content so we can
use this to extrapolate
the present state back in time by using
those equations
and so what happens is that at some
point those equations just break down
and we end up with a state at which the
energy density and also the curvature of
the universe was infinitely large so
this is what's called the big bang
and
now the problem is that
most physicists me included think that
this is probably not what actually
happened it just means that those
equations break down and we would have
to use a better theory so that would be
a quantum theory of gravity but we don't
have it so
how did the universe begin well we don't
know because we don't have this theory
now of course a lot of physicists are
unhappy with this state of affairs
and
what they try to do is that they kind of
modify the equations at an early time
and then they attach a different story
to the beginning of the universe so
instead of a big bang you might instead
have a big bounce like this is something
which is popular in certain cycles so
you have a previous universe which
collapses and then it starts to expand
again so there's this bounce in the
middle and those bounces could repeat
and then you get a cyclic universe but
doesn't have to be the case in some in
some scenarios it's just single bounds
um but it could be other things you know
and other people have claimed that we
came out of a black hole and it could
have been a higher dimensional black
hole so it could have five dimensions or
it could have been some kind of
collision between higher dimensional
membranes or something with a gas of
strings or some people say maybe it
didn't have any geometry but it was just
some kind of network so there are all
kinds of stories and the problem i have
with those stories is that they make a
simple story more complicated which
isn't something that a scientist should
do so i think the honest answer uh
can give as physicists to the question
how did the universe begin is we don't
know
what that i know this is unsatisfactory
but i think that that's that's how it is
what is the fundamental problem
that physicists are bouncing up against
or coming up against bounce might be the
wrong word
with all of these uh extravagant
stories that they're trying to tell
about what might have happened before
the big bang or to create the big bang
what is the fundamental problem is it
the something from nothing
um that's actually an even more
difficult problem no it's got something
to do with the with the type of theory
that we currently use um which is this
combination of um
a description of the state of a system
at one moment in time it's normally
called an initial state but somewhat
confusingly could also be at the final
time um so this is just um one
specification of the state at one moment
in time and then we have some equation
by which we can tell from this one
initial state what happens at any other
time
and so the way that it works for the
universe is that we take an initial
state uh in in the early phase of the
universe it can't be exactly at the big
bang because as i said this is a
singularity so it doesn't work but it
could be something after this and then
you apply um your evolution law so in
the simplest case that that's just
einstein's equations uh and then you can
calculate how the universe should look
like today and you can compare this uh
two observations and if it works you say
bingo okay good theory
uh and and now if you look at at all
those other explanations basically what
you do is you you attach a more
complicated story before this
and um this is something which you can
always do um it's allowed by our
theories uh but it makes the theory
completely ambiguous because there are
many different ways that you can do it
and it's jump something that the
scientific method um actually doesn't
allow
um which is why i think it's it's a
problem that we can't really resolve
with the theories that we currently have
it's it's possible that at some point
we'll come up with a different type of
theory um that might be able to overcome
this limitation but at least for now i i
think we're stuck with it it seems to me
like
there's a lot of problems or phys
theoretical physics is kind of bouncing
off the limit of a bunch of the current
theories that we have i had michio kaku
on the show speaking to him and it
seemed like his explanations there's
always caveats here and there there's
always something that's like oh we don't
quite know about this but it's sort of a
best guess and we've got this but we
need to add 11 dimensions in order to
make it work and there's a lot of
assumptions like i'm i you know i
appreciate i'm bro sciencing my way
through this right but
it it seems like the
the ha
it seems unsubstantial or insubstantial
at the moment what we have to describe
the universe and that this is causing
people to retrofit stories around what's
happening in order to be able to make
the theories work
yes right and all of this is entirely
unnecessary to actually explain what we
observe so so that's the problem with it
so you so you get those uh multiple
stories um that can all be made to fit
to the current observations and then if
you turn if you turn it around
it has the consequence that you can't
use observations to tell those stories
apart
interesting one
talking about how the universe began
what about how it's going to end are we
big crunch big freeze
what's the other one big heat is there a
heat definitely
big grip yeah big grip death there's
also one of them okay how are we going
to end how's it how's it all going to
finish yeah i'm afraid the answers again
we don't know um in in this case it's i
think it's easier to understand so if
we're trying to say how the universe is
going to end we have to extrapolate the
current state of the universe uh into
the future possibly over trillions of
years
um and
the problem is that there could be some
physical processes that are just very
rare uh and or they are so small that we
haven't been able to measure them
well one example could be that the
cosmological constant is not actually
constant but it might very very slightly
been changing and now over over
trillions of years or something like
this this could be
the decisive factor for the fate of the
universe and it's just something that we
we can never rule out so basically what
happens is that if we extrapolate the
current state into the future the the
uncertainty just blows up and in the end
you can't say anything
so it's kind of an interesting mind
game i guess to try to figure out
assuming that nothing else happens like
the cosmological concept is actually
constant and there are no other
processes that we haven't yet heard of
and so on and so forth you can try to
speculate what's going to happen but i
would say don't take it too seriously
if nothing was to change if there's no
uh spooky alterations hiding in the
future what do you think would be most
likely to expect in that case
um i think if i if i remember correctly
um at least in the current standard
model of cosmology it'd be the heat
death so it's because the cosmological
constant uh speeds up um the expansion
of the universe so the um
galaxies become more and more distant to
each other and then the stars gradually
die and they collapse to black holes
everything everything will be dark and
then the black holes evaporate and you
have this leftover gas of elementary
particles and
that's pretty much it but i mean if you
have another theory like uh roger
penrose for example has this idea of a
cyclic universe then the whole thing
eventually
transitions into a new
kind of big bang so i know this is
making this a little bit
vague but i mean he has some mathematics
to show for
and i think it's not entirely crazy i i
actually have quite some sympathy for it
but i'm not really sold on it i guess
would you say speaking of mathematics
and roger penrose's work is
is mathematics like the ultimate
language or the basis of reality is that
what everything is built on
yeah that's a very interesting question
believe it or not i've actually thought
about this for for quite some bit uh but
it's certainly the case that currently
it's the best thing that we have
and i think it'll continue to be the
best thing uh for quite some time we
haven't fully exploited its potential
especially when it comes to a chaotic or
complex systems that we just talked
about we've barely begun to understand
how the mathematics works
um but how
how are we to tell if that's the best
thing
ultimately like we we've barely just
begun to understand nature and to try to
formulate our uh hypotheses about it uh
in in forms of mathematics maybe in a
hundred thousand years somebody will
come up with something better than
mathematics
what el what else could there be i don't
understand what could be better than
mathematics
well yeah i guess that's the problem
right maybe we're just not smart enough
um
so um i i certainly hope that um
given time there will be a more
a more sophisticated
species on this planet and god knows
what they will come up with but one
thing that i've played with um is that
it is
in principle possible to do science
without using mathematics as an
intermediary and we actually do this
when we do computer simulations to some
extent so the way that we currently do
computer simulations is that we
um we take the mathematics that
we have extracted from from observations
and then we formulated in terms of an
algorithm and we put that on a computer
so we use mathematics as this middleman
um to get the simulation but strictly
speaking you don't actually need this
you could try to find
another system
that
mimics the thing you want to describe
directly and actually um this is being
done
in quantum simulations so there
for one thing there are certain types of
quantum computers uh that are based on
this idea
but more generally you can
you can simulate certain
the properties of certain fundamental
particles for example the higgs is one
example that people have looked at but
also things like madrana particles and
so on you can simulate them in condensed
metal systems
and um now
again this is
using mathematics as an intermediary yes
but strictly speaking you don't you
don't need it you could just say well i
take the simulation in and by itself and
i just try to figure out what it tells
me about this other system so so you can
map reality directly to reality and i
think that that's kind of a different
way to do science that we haven't
explored further enough and maybe that's
that's the way that we would
be able to go beyond mathematics at some
point but this is like really really far
out their wildest speculation
is it true that other alien
civilizations would have had to have
discovered mathematics as well i often
hear about mathematics being a universal
language of the universe and stuff like
that is there any legs to that
it seems very plausible to me but
how we to know we we haven't spoken to
any alien species um so i mean it's
certainly it's certainly the case that
mathematics is kind of
a universal description of certain
regularities
um and and so it seems plausible to me
that this probably would have been the
case but um i guess we'll have to wait
until we meet those audience to find out
i suppose if you were to think about any
alien sat on its little green planet and
it was to look up at the sky at night
and it would say there is
a
point of light in the sky there is
another point of light in the sky there
is another point of light in the sky
like i guess inferred from that is
look that is the fundamental basis of
counting right there's you've got some
mathematics in front of you and i guess
everything else from there all the way
up to equals m c squared is just more of
counting counting stuff and manipulating
it
yeah that that's how the argument uh
normally goes but but again i mean this
is kind of very strongly based on our
experience of the world um
so how are we to tell that not aliens uh
would see reality completely differently
um
you mentioned earlier on about the
cosmological constant which is
part of this
is used to justify the fine-tuned theory
of the universe the fact that you have
this unbelievable sort of knife edge
that a bunch of different uh
characteristics of this universe gravity
strong weak nuclear force cosmological
constant and am i right in thinking that
if any one of these was even
ever so slightly different that
basically we probably wouldn't exist and
the likelihood of it occurring seems
super super low and therefore people say
look this is obvious that the universe
has been fine-tuned for life
but that's also super contested can you
go into the fine-tuning theory for me
yeah so this is an argument which has
been made for a long time and it works
pretty much the way that you just
summarize that you you take those
constants that we have
in the fundamental laws of nature um i
think that 26 of them depends on how you
count you know a lot of those constants
are just zero for we know like the mass
of the photon and then you can you can
argue over it does it count as a
constant if it's zero
um
so you know a splitting has but um yes
so you can ask stuff like if the
cosmological constant was a little bit
larger uh or if it was a little bit
smaller what would happen and
or you can ask about
the fine structure constant um
the fine structure constant that's the
sets the strength of the electromagnetic
interaction alpha
um so so what would happen if we made
this a little bit larger or smaller or
the gravitational uh constant and so on
and so forth and in in a lot of those
cases the answer is something would go
badly wrong
stars wouldn't be able to shine
or
the galaxies would never be able to form
everything would collapse to black holes
the entire universe might collapse
immediately or it would be impossible to
form any kind of complex molecules that
we think are
necessary for life
and
people have gone through a lot of
examples of that type
and
some have taken this as an opportunity
to say
well that looks really unlikely that
something like this would have happened
by chance there must have been a creator
um
and then there are on the other side
there are physicists to say well this
seems very unlikely to have been the
case therefore there must be a
multiverse so they're kind of two sides
of the same uh coins so to say um
although they're both uh
exactly opposite uh to some extent but
they come out of the same idea which is
that
it seems like there's something in need
of an explanation which is why are the
constants of nature exactly those
now the problem with this entire
argument is that we have no way of
quantifying the probability of this
happening so if you tell me well it
seems really unlikely i would ask you
well um how do you know i mean it's not
like you can collect a sample and ask
how often does it happen because we have
only this one set of constants of nature
and we have no way of telling how likely
or unlikely it would have been um so
typically these arguments work with um
some kind of statement about what is or
isn't a small change in the constants of
nature but this you can also question
like how small is small
and
why is this
too small and why not this other thing
and so i think this is all ill-defined
and i'm i'm totally unconvinced by any
of those arguments there's also the
curious fact um that in the past couple
of years you wouldn't believe it but
every once in a while there's actually
progress on these matters um
some physicists have come up with
possible combinations of the constants
of nature that are very different from
the ones that we have in our universe
but that still seem to allow for complex
chemistry uh to happen so physicists
don't really talk about life but it
seems quite plausible
that these these other combinations of
the constants of nature would also allow
for um complex chemistry and possibly
even life so um you know i think this
this argument is really just wrong and
people should stop talking about it
well it's cool to think that there's
another combination out there that would
allow complex uh
life to evolve because that i mean that
would do away with the fine-tuned theory
overall right that you have another
version of this that could work and i i
really like the idea that
even though if we were to look i think
it's the cosmological constant that's a
a very small number there's a couple of
others it's like the weak nuclear force
is an unbelievably small number compared
with some other numbers that are in the
bunch of constants
but when you talk about how much you
want to change that by as you said who
is to define what would be a large or a
small change who is to define whether
that's a large or a small number
and then when you talk about something
being fine-tuned by design you're
talking about something being moved by
small amounts but if you're the person
that's already creating before that
a decision on what big and small is then
it's just you making i guess like a
value judgment or a pre-designed
judgement on whether or not you think it
should change
yeah that's one way to look at it um
normally um
physicists rather arbitrarily say um if
if a change is of size one then that's
large uh and everything that's below
that or that becomes very subjective but
then you can say is it smaller than one
over a hundred or is it smaller than one
over a thousand uh that would be small
but of course you could just have
started with um as you say one over a
thousand uh or something and then
measure everything relative to that
um and and so th this is exactly where
this argument that physicist put forward
becomes circular
what's your view on boltzmann brains i
learned about these last year that
there's potentially other versions of us
floating out there in the ether and that
me and you and this entire conversation
might just be the brief flickering of
some brain a million trillion billion
miles away from here uh and i might just
be imagining it all
yeah so um indeed it might not have been
uh a whole version of you but maybe just
your brain which uh has the illusion
that it's talking to me
um yes so that that's one thing which um
comes out of
statistical mechanics if you take it too
seriously um so
basically the idea is that if the
universe goes on forever which um as we
already discussed previously
is likely to happen if you just
extrapolate the current state into the
future
then all kinds of combinations of
fundamental particles that are in the
universe should happen at some point
provided the laws of nature fulfill a
certain property which is called ergodic
which i'll come back to
in a second and then it can happen that
just
coincidentally you know the um
elementary particles combine to form
some particular molecule
and it takes a really long time you know
we're talking trillions and trillions of
years
um and then you wait a little bit longer
and they combine to form something like
that's like a cell and if you wait long
enough it would form a brain and then in
fact if you just wait long enough it'll
form any possible brain
brains that will think all possible
thoughts
but the downside of this is
that the larger the thing
the shorter it'll persist because it's
surrounded by all this randomness
which which comes from the interaction
of the other molecules which have not
spontaneously similar to a large thing
so um the shorter the thing lives the
more likely it is and this is what gives
rise to this idea of the boltzmann
brains so somewhere at the end of the
universe in the very very far future
there are all those brains spontaneously
assembling it's themselves just thinking
one thought oh hello i'm here or hello
i'm talking to sabine and then they they
fall apart again and i see you laughing
and hey yeah it seems a little bit
ridiculous
um
but the thing is that if you if you
take this seriously what we know about
uh the fundamental lost nature and about
statistical mechanics then you kind of
have to bite into this sour apple
um i think that's a german idiom but i
hope it i hope it translates
and so a lot of people think this is
just silly but i think it actually tells
us something about the loss of nature
because if you want to
prevent this from happening then we can
conclude that the laws of nature can't
be ergodic
and that's a statement about the
properties of those fundamental laws
there are actually some indications i
should add that um gravity or quite
possibly the strong nuclear force might
not be ergodic and so i think that this
is an
interesting factual and so it's not
quite as silly as it sounds as at first
why would forces
change within the same universe just
because they're far away
oh um no the the forces don't change so
the argument is that this um
um this statement that all possible
combinations of fundamental particles
happen at some time this is only correct
for um laws of nature that have certain
properties so um and this is this uh
economicity and this is basically what
it means so if the theory's ergotic then
then all these possible things will
happen uh at some point but this is not
the case for all possible interactions
that you can think of in particular if
you have some interactions that are very
strongly bound which the strong nuclear
forces it makes it highly implausible
you know but you you you take you put
some particles together and they get
stuck like in a bound state like the
strong nuclear force uh binds together
quarks in a proton uh or something like
this
um
why should everything that can happen um
also actually happen at some point why
can't they just why can't they just
remain stuck together forever
and then so this kind of interaction uh
runs you into problem like problems like
this and
to be fair boltzmann when he was
thinking about this didn't know anything
about the strong nuclear force so
probably it just wasn't a problem that
didn't occur to him does that mean that
it's wrong to say that me and you would
be having this conversation further away
is that the same the exact same model
that people are using that if the
universe outside of the observable
universe is infinite then it means that
mean you are having this conversation a
million different times in a million
different ways
well the way that i would put it is that
it's either that or the laws of nature
are not ergotic and then we learn
something from it
interesting what do you mean you talk
about knowledge and humans being
predictable what do you mean there
um actually david deutsch talks about
this so i went and interviewed um david
deutsch which was
very interesting and he has this
argument uh that knowledge uh can't be
predictable because if you could uh
predict the knowledge uh from what we
already know then it wouldn't be new
knowledge
which makes sense
and i think it's also something
um that we
see happening in
in physics but also in other disciplines
of science is that any kind of new
theory that we develop um it requires
this intuitive leap it requires
something
new you can't just strictly speaking
deduce it from what came previously so
you what you see a lot is that in
hindsight
physicists often make up some kind of
story for how they came to this
conclusion it was deduced from what they
had previously heard and so on and so
forth but it seems to me there's always
like an element of magic in between
somewhere you know where where there's
this inside which comes in and i think
this is this is what what david uh is
getting at i should say though that this
is like something at the at a very high
emergent level um you could you know on
the level that we are talking about it
um you could make an argument that
fundamentally if you're talking about uh
course includes and the the laws that
they behave um by
it might well have been deterministic uh
it's just that uh for practical purposes
we we would never have been able to
predict it
do you think does that mean that
knowledge is discovered or created
well
i guess both right
so
[Music]
sometimes some types of knowledge
you discover
um others you create
i i don't i i know people discuss this a
lot when it comes to mathematics but
i've always been kind of a little bit
ambiguous about it i don't see that it
has to be one or the other it could well
be it could well be both got you when it
comes to consciousness as well obviously
we've spoken about free will spoken
about simulation
is it possible for us to compute
consciousness
um
that's a very good question um as you
probably know roger penrose um
takes the point of view that it's not
possible um here's an argument that's
based on uh goodell's theorem and i have
an interview with him in my book about
it i'm i'm not really convinced by this
argument uh but then you know he's a
nobel prize winner and i'm not so maybe
you should listen to him and not to me
and this is why i have the interviews in
my books and you don't just hear what i
think
um so he thinks there's an an
uncomputable element uh to consciousness
and um so the laws of nature that we
currently use they are computable and i
think this is one of the reasons why he
thinks um that there is something about
quantum mechanics uh which we don't yet
fully understand and so he has put
forward some uh alternative uh theories
to quantum mechanics where um he thinks
this element of consciousness uh comes
in um so i think it's interesting um i
i'm not convinced that it it's quite
right but then maybe there's something
worthwhile um to it
so if he's right then it would mean that
um artificial intelligence at least in
the in the way that we can
currently formulate it in terms of
algorithms run on computers would never
be really conscious yeah well i think
that's
maybe about 10 years ago when did super
intelligence come out 2014 nick
bostrom's book something like that
when that came out and i read that i was
adamant that the
artificial general intelligence
apocalypse was going to be with us
within 10 or 15 years uh and it seems
like the ai safety community the
discussion around agi in general has
kind of switched a little bit in that
time it's not like i've got my finger on
the pulse of the coolest stuff in the
development of it but just from my sort
of perspective and it seems now like
well-defined problems are things that
artificial intelligence is getting
incredibly good at and poorly defined
problems basically haven't made
much progress at all as far as i can see
and it's the poorly defined problems
that are precisely where the general
from
agi would come from and i think that
it seems like some of the uh what did
they call embostradamus
um some of the uh bostradamus concerns
the pre-apocalyptic people
it seems like that's changed it seems
like the narrative around this sort of
discussion has changed precisely because
of the fact that we're having more and
more difficulty in computing this stuff
yeah it's very interesting um they're
also increasingly running into resource
limits um as my understanding like those
computing power
yeah computing power energy um and then
there's the problem that you know all
the stuff with the uh what are they
called the hyperparameters that have to
be
found out somehow and
oh those um neural networks that are
typically used for artificial
intelligence um they
have what's called hyperparameters that
have to be chosen um so the network can
properly learn and that's a little bit
of black magic like where do those hyper
parameters come from and that there's a
lot of discussion at least that's my
understanding and like you i don't
really work on this i'm just following
it from the outside um that um
because of this black magic it's kind of
irreproducible what what they achieve
because you don't know how did they come
up with those parameters how often did
they try it how often did they fail um
and so there's now um a move in in the
community whether where they're trying
to make this more transparent so that
it's it's easier to figure out what was
actually done
i
i
part of me feels
grateful i think that giving a
uh
self reprogramming super intelligent agi
a little bit more time to come around
while we could perhaps get some more
wisdom to come along with the technology
that seems like a pretty good idea to me
uh even if it's not by choice it's
simply by programming language
restriction and our own
lack of ability to write whatever it is
that we need to write part of that feels
like
probably a good thing i think overall i
think that technology outstrips wisdom
and
the fact that we're hitting some real
roadblocks is is interesting is am i
right in thinking that moore's law the
computing power doubles every two years
on average that that's actually
beginning to slow as well
i've i've heard this too but then i've
heard other people objecting to it
and so i'm really not a technology
person so i'm not entirely sure who to
trust uh but yeah so so the the death of
moore's law um
has been proclaimed a few times already
so at this point i'm not really sure to
trust there's also this entire problem
that with the world economy after the
pandemic and all the supply chain issues
it might not you know it might be an
anomaly in the data so it's maybe maybe
a little bit unfair yes of course that
makes sense how come how come nobody
gets any younger why
why aren't any of us getting any younger
yeah so that's an interesting question
um
in that we've we believe we figured out
part of the answer um so in in physics
this goes under the problem of the era
of time why does time
seem to look different in one direction
than in the other
and
we believe we understand part of it part
of it is just that
certain chains of events
are very likely to happen whereas others
are unlikely so things are likely to
break um
disorder is likely to increase um but
it's very unlikely that things
spontaneously unbreak and it's very
unlikely for
orders spontaneously to decrease which
is just another way of saying that
entropy normally increases
but this of course brings up the
question like if entropy constantly
increases why was it small in the past
to begin with and um the way that we
currently deal with it is that we just
say well the universe was born with a
small entropy and we have no idea why
and that makes everything work and then
that's true but it it we have no idea
why this was the case and it's again
it's a question about the initial state
which we already discussed when we were
talking about the beginning of the
universe so it's one of those um issues
where we we currently don't even know
how to answer the question it's one of
the it's a question that pendulus is
actually trying to answer with his um
cyclic universe
and
how do you envision from a physics
perspective how do you envision time is
everything happening at once
well um
at least in our current theories time is
the dimension
um so of course if you map out space and
time then it's not that everything is
happening at once um it's just that
the whole thing together is one
mathematical construct that just sits
there it's not that there's one
particular moment which we call the
present moment that is special in any
regard i mean it's special in our
perception but then you could say in our
perception uh each moment is special at
some moment in time so in that sense
they're all equal if that makes sense
would this be kind of the same as saying
because i'm stood in this spot right now
this is the spot which is special to me
but if i was stood in a slightly
different spot that would be in terms of
the three dimensions right of space
and time is it sort of an equally
arbitrary choice of now and then now and
then now again
yeah it's very similar except that in
space you can go back and forth whereas
in time you can't why is that the case
that there is an arrow of time that it
has directionality at all
well that's what i just said we have
only um half of the answer right so if
you're asking like why can't you go back
in time it's because you were already
there
and um so if you were allowed to um to
do it a second time then that could lead
to all kinds of uh causal products this
is the the usual problem with with time
trouble i'm afraid so that and it's not
going to happen
uh well if you say so look sabine
hostenfelder ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with the
stuff that you're doing you've got your
youtube channel which is blowing up now
in your twitter and your new book where
should they go
um
well just google my name because it's
not a very common name and you'll find
more out about me than you ever wanted
to know
sabine i appreciate you thank you
thank you what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]